there's a con what are they calling it
um what
what are they calling it in new york oh
yeah it's not a corner zone it's not
quarantine it's a containment
containment zone in new york they're not
quarantined they're just contained
and here's the thing they're calling
infinitely they're calling it a suburb
and that's technically true
the new rochelle area new york has
called in the national guard
and it's it's the what do they say was
the biggest cluster of
of cases in the united states that's
scary because it's
right next to the bronx which is right
next to manhattan
and if that's the biggest cluster and
they just are finding out that it's
there
it's it's the biggest city in the
country i mean i was talking about it
population
i would not want to go to new york i
avoided going to new york i was going to
go
this weekend it's like no no no no i'm
good yeah it's your birthday too no no
no
i mean it was but i wasn't going to new
york but for our birthday we have
zombies
not risking it not really zombies no
freak out everybody
so um well as we let's let's first read
about what actually happened because no
it's not zombies it's a drunk guy
drunk people sometimes do this stuff so
you know don't freak out but uh
hop into super chats if you want us to
read some of your comments and you know
we gotta
you know what man i'm gonna tell you
something every single story today was
chronovirus it was nuts
i know it's really annoying i was i was
sitting here getting bored with it
it's frustrating it's frustrating
because there's other things in the
world
that get shut down because literally
everything is an iteration of some
chronovirus story
true and i'm just like dude i can't do
it because you you oh it's just nuts
and so i said you know what man i don't
normally we have like a bunch of
different story ideas we got a couple
like
things that are interesting we don't
talk about but it's just everything
chronovirus because it's a lot like
political rallies are being shut down
the the the the democratic debate with
which i guess joe biden is requested to
sit down at
i'm not kidding are you serious yeah i
can't stand for two hours
no he can't but they're getting rid of
the audience wow it's crazy like the
yeah so so anyway let's let's read about
let's just get to it i don't wanna i
don't wanna
you know waste your time let's read
about this drunk man stripping down to
his underpants in a subway station and
biting
anti-coronavirus officers after refusing
to have his temperature taken
from the daily mail they say a drunk
chinese man
has been detained after stripping down
to his underwear okay read that
the intoxicated passenger known by his
surname wang
okay shouted i'll strip naked for your
checks
after he was stopped by the station's
staff hey no that's not funny
it is a serious medical issue he's
tripped naked his name's wang
i have to laugh hey bigots all right
biggest oh man it's comedy keep your
bigotry out of here
bigots i said i will strip naked for
your checks after he was stopped by the
station's staff members for a
temperature test last wednesday evening
look aren't i pretty said the barely
dressed mr wang to the staff of the
metro
in nanjing jiangsu province in eastern
china according to local press
if this is how the zombie apocalypse
starts i am down
like could you imagine 28 days later and
it's like you wake up from a coma
and like the world's destroyed and
there's like a guy with a beard and like
he's like a shotgun
and you're confused about what's
happening and you're like mister what
happened he's like get down hide
28 days ago wang got naked and bit some
crown of my wait wait wait hold on
who wang got naked that's what happened
that is not scary that's weird cctv
footage shows the half-naked man pushing
away the officers
who are trying to put clothes back on mr
wing
so look at this there's photos of it i
wonder why he got naked
dude this photo looks like the guy
cracked him over the back like he's a
full-on punch just boom
no look see this it looks like he's
holding like a sack of quarters
you know what i mean and it's like boom
over the back of the head
we're going to get so much trouble for
this segment on youtube they're going to
be like you are you are yeah you are not
for kids
well i mean that's a good thing the
wobbly passenger even bit two
anti-chronov
conaronovirus workers as he was being
tackled the ground this is literally how
zombie movies start now the
anti-coronavirus workers are now
zombies well so never know but like go
to sleep next in the movies
in the movie there'll be someone sick
and then they'll be like he's just sick
and then he'll bite him like oh he bit
me what
why would he do that and then yeah later
they go home to their family and
everything seems fine at the dinner
table and then all of a sudden
no no their skin is like really pale and
like they have rings on their eyes and
the wife's are you okay you don't look
so good he's like
you know it's like shauna the dead when
the roommate who's like some guy bit me
i don't know
he's like they're like why would a
mugger bet you was like i didn't stop to
ask him
yeah it's like they don't know why the
police told the press that mr wang went
to a friend's dinner party before he
arrived at the subway station
he was already feeling dizzy as he left
his friend's house
he's drunk alcohol but but is it subway
stations around china have set up
checkpoints take passengers temperatures
as a precaution against the chronovirus
china has recently seen a sharp drop in
its new cases of the deadly disease i
don't buy it
because everyone's locked in their house
exactly
they lock everybody up they stop testing
new people because everyone's locked in
i think i don't i don't know if they're
not testing anybody anymore but i've
heard that
that they basically just told everyone
you can't come out stay home
there's a story it's really crazy that
some doctors in the early stages started
reporting this
and the police immediately stepped in
and were like shut up
whoa yeah yeah yeah so that's basically
the story and then they go and talk
about how you know like the the corn
virus is spreading and stuff
so now that we've talked about the
silliness of a guy who just was it look
let's let's be real
you know it's funny to hear a story
about a crazy guy during this plague you
know whatever you want to call it
outbreak i shouldn't say plague
it's it's a funny story when a guy like
strips an egg and then bites somebody
his name happens to be wang it's like
it falls into a bunch of stereotypes and
stuff now we're gonna get in trouble but
no but not but but in all seriousness
let's get to the serious bit
new york is like we're we're we are
minutes away
from full-on quarantine yeah yeah
because we are following
the the exact trajectory that italy
basically went through
first thing was a few isolated cases and
they were like it's no big deal just
stay home if you're sick don't go to
work
and then all of a sudden they were like
okay we're going to be shutting down
some some you know events and gatherings
like
people should stay home don't go out if
you don't have to we're going to try and
do a soft quarantine on this one
then it went hard quarantine in the
northern region and they were like okay
armed police guarding roads no one can
come near
and now the whole country is locked down
but apparently i'm still hearing that
like flights are coming in and out so
i have no idea what that means what i
think it means is basically
what italy has done different from china
is that you're technically free to go
but everything's closed
businesses are all closed events are all
cancelled so
you can leave your house but there's
nothing anywhere yeah everything's
closed
that's basically what they're doing now
in new york so this one area
uh well i shouldn't say well it is new
york state
new rochelle is what like 10 miles from
new york city proper
they they call it a suburb and i'm like
yeah it's the wall street journal so
they understand why it is
but i think people might think that it
means it's not close to the city no it
is
it is basically the bronx because the
bronx is here
new rochelle is there that manhattan's
here it's like what's the difference
it's like another it's another yeah it's
a new year
yeah it's still in the subways that's
why i think it's weird they're calling
it the suburb
because like if if you're in chicago
there's uh where i grew up on the south
side there's
technically if you cross a street in
chicago anymore you're in a suburb i
mean staten island is
is all suburbs no it's new york city it
is
also i know you go to staten island it's
like it's more suburb land than
new orleans yeah of course if you were
in the southern tip like if you're in
the
south staten island yeah you're probably
further from the city than you would be
if you were in newark oh for sure
and but but technically it's not true
because staten island is the city
yeah it's staten island's jersey i know
i'm you tell them that they're gonna get
mad at you that's okay i said
so let's let's let's there's actually i
have a friend from staten island who
told me that
so for the record a staten island knight
told me that i don't even know if that's
how you say it but all right boom what
does it mean you guys want to see the
real freaky stuff though
oh boy no no no no no no i don't want to
see it check it out
first coachella's being postponed man oh
no no instagram influencers are
are so upset it was like a million fake
instagram accounts
let out a cry and were silenced all at
once or whatever god
no but here's the actual scary story so
this is from uh more from the daily mail
europe engulfed by coronavirus angela
merkel warns up to 58 million germans
60 to 70 of the population will be
infected
as spain sees infections triple in two
days and italy records 168 fatalities
in one day in one day is that
i mean how many deaths does the flu
hit in one day in italy i'm just curious
i know i know there's an exponential
growth happening here and that's the
scary part that's the problem well so
the first problem i have with the flu
comparison
is like just because the flu is bad
doesn't mean this isn't bad no no i know
that and then but then people are like
do you overreact for the flu it's like
dude people go out and get flu shots all
the time
right we don't even have coronavirus so
if they're saying this is
34 times as deadly as the flu traveling
just as fast
okay and then if they're like with the
flu killed more people like well yeah
but we've been tracking the flu since
october and this outbreak just started
and even if you know this is just
another flu like it's gonna be the same
thing
yeah we have a whole international
apparatus for dealing with flu yeah
you're right we take it very seriously
you go to the store you go to the store
and they're like did you get your flu
shot
like they they they actively take
measures to to protect against flu and
they do tell people like if you have the
flu stay home wash your hands yeah it's
true
it's flu season take things seriously
what i was reading one story and they
said everything we're hearing right now
in terms of the directions for the
public is the exact same thing they say
for for uh flu outbreaks so like wash
your hands limit contact
somebody uh i can't remember who where i
was reading this but it was about like
the
the cdc recommendations they said older
people should stock up
and then there was an article i was
reading where they basically said this
is just typical
for any illness and we need to be
reacting much much more
like i don't know panicked in a sense
okay
yeah there are actually some people
arguing for panic not even kidding
there was uh i can't i can't remember
who wrote this but i saw it on twitter
and they said the argument for panicking
in the coronavirus outbreak
and they said the worst case scenario
for
you know if if no one does anything is
that the medical system becomes
completely strained
right there's a there's a graphic it was
on the front page of reddit like number
one
and they show that if we limit exposure
and reduce
the infection rate we'll probably still
see the same amount of people infected
but over a longer period of time which
means the medical system can
can stabilize it flattens out the curve
i actually was looking at this earlier
today i sent it to my family because i
was like
if we start limiting our exposure we
might actually stay under the dotted
line which is medical
capacity right i really like to stay
under that dotted line and now let's
let's
now let me give you all a sad a sad sad
wake-up call check this out
the mortality rate is substantially
higher than 3.4 percent
for one reason they're basing the
mortality rate off of
everyone so a 25 year old dude who gets
this is gonna get the sniffles
yeah he's gonna he's gonna cough gonna
get a cold and the mortality rate for
you know a 25 year old is ridiculously
low
the average age i think that is what i
read for more for the death was like 81
yeah that's the average the average age
but where's it happening that's death
but that's still like but not older than
that no but then think about all the
young people who are being added to the
mortality rate
reducing that percentage making it seem
like it's not that bad
right the real issue is that for for um
high-risk individuals which is elderly
people
uh people with like lung illnesses heart
illnesses the mortality rate can be up
to eight percent
yeah that's high so you you hear these
stories about
you know people who got sick and they
asked like well do they have any pre
did they have pre-existing conditions
and it's like one of them did yes
and that's kind of the point like we get
it like the flu can do this too
so i think the the main issue here
especially when people are comparing it
to the flu
it's like well you know i'm i'm almost
tired of saying it but i know we have no
immunity to this
right like the flu we do and if the
mortality rate is even 34 times
higher in general let alone
substantially higher what is that 800
time or
yeah 800 times no no i'm sorry 80 times
higher for
elderly people yeah i mean yeah we got a
serious problem i mean if it's
if it's just three percent what's three
percent of 58 million germans
i mean that's that's a lot of i'm just
looking at this article and that's like
she's saying that 58 million germans are
gonna have it that's 60
70 of the population in germany and it's
like that's
i've driven around europe it is so easy
to go
from country to country there is no it's
like it's like the states
yeah exactly like the state so if it hit
italy as hard as it did it's definitely
gonna hit all over because people don't
know they're traveling around it's like
so we're in uh we're in south jersey
which but which is basically the philly
suburbs
we're apparently under a state of
emergency yeah i guess that's what what
happened and uh we've had one debt here
in the state
cbs is now reporting 31 dead in the u.s
as states scramble to contain the virus
and this is the latest update
so let me just read some of this to say
u.s officials are racing to implement
new measures to stop the spread of
coronavirus
which has killed at least 31 people and
sickened nearly a thousand
more than 15 15 states have declared a
state of emergency
to help free up resources 15 it was nine
states earlier yeah well
they're they're man so uh let me let me
just throw one yet checks out bernie
sanders and joe biden both cancel
rallies tonight in cleveland
and cnn nix's live audience for sunday
debate between two democratic contenders
man there was a period about you know
probably last week where i felt like
things were calming down
yeah like they're getting they're under
control and we were gonna chill and it's
like all right looks like everything's
good
now it seems like the apocalypse is
staring us in the face you know we got
the guy biting people
and the guy at cpac that like they found
had it so now all these are shaking from
his hands yeah
yeah but getting so self quarantined but
even uh there's a democrat now do you
know who that was
uh i forget his name but there's so a
democrat it's not self-quarantining and
matt hates does not have it
they found so he tested negative he's
still yeah and quarantined
smart boy um but i don't know who that
democrat was but
it's spreading through those ranks yeah
everyone's like it's there you go both
parties
so hopefully it doesn't get as bad as it
did with uh
iran when there's a 10 of their
parliament getting it and a bunch of
them died
but here's the thing about what angela
merkel is saying 60 to 70 percent of
german's population
there was last month an expert i believe
they testified before the senate saying
they think the worst case scenario for
this is sixty percent global
global infection rate yeah which means n
at that at
we're talking about 90 to 90 some odd
million people dead that's insane that's
a lot
that's a ridiculous that's a lot and i
think it was with a low estimate
it's like 45 and the high demand is 90
million dead
i mean 45 million as a low is a lot
millions of people that's a lot but
let's talk about the real tragedy here
oh yeah yeah yeah what are we like what
are we supposed to do we just sit around
and
eat pancakes like yes can't go sporting
events can't go to
music shows well they're saying that
once it gets hot outside it can't
survive
is that not true i don't know but you
know you know what's really
what really makes me angry i was so
excited to go to this joe biden rally
just like millions of other americans
sure
i'm sure you are i sure was gonna take
the van down by the river and cleveland
uh no no but there is one other thing
that i find really really interesting in
all this because we were talking about
it earlier
if if i were to ask you who do you think
is more likely to prep or a democrat or
republican
which would you pick i my mind had an
answer
i would i would have said republicans
right but it's not true
you'd be wrong but i but then i would
think about it be like why does it
matter
like there's different people in all
different it's the weirdest thing
i think it's because trump has been
downplaying this telling people
it's gonna be like so trump's supporters
trust him
and you know so they're like i i you
know take his word for it's gonna be
fine we're gonna you know do our thing
and the democrats are screaming the end
is nigh and like
yeah you know what man this is the
problem with polarized partisan politics
i've i i don't i don't know what what
trump's answer needs to be
because you can't make panic i mean
everyone just needs to wash their hands
come on people
wash your hands it's not that though
it's in your eyes it's it exists wash
your eyeballs
wash your eyeballs man get some bio
truffle
no but uh uh like there's a video that
went viral from australia
and they play like this dramatic
orchestral music
and it shows a store opening and
everyone rushes full speed to the toilet
paper
and just starts stopping like black
friday but here's the other day here's
the thing man
if there's a viral outbreak you know
what you shouldn't do go crowd up with a
bunch of other people go crowd up with a
bunch of other people
right and and also if you're concerned
about a shortage of supplies you know
what you shouldn't do
what buy a ton of toilet paper i don't
understand have you considered
maybe i don't know buying food right
that you can eat yeah i don't understand
the whole toilet paper craze
i really don't i don't get it dude i
don't know and it's australia too do
they like what
maybe they only eat chipotle over there
you know so they just constantly
blow out the bathroom remember it
reminds me of what's the south park joke
reminds me of uh parks
parks and rec when chris pratt's like he
i'm not gonna
say the whole joke but he's basically
like is this normal cause
it's kind of like wiping a marker like
oh my
dude fox and rex mike chris pratt's
funny guy but
that's what i think of it was uh was it
jesse kelly he was like these people
think they're they're gonna wipe their
butts through this outbreak like that's
gonna how they're gonna survive
yep apparently i had no idea we gotta
just get bidets
let's let's do it well that was another
thing someone else tweeted they're great
and other news i've tried it once
yeah i miss it it was like 10 years ago
i still think about it about it but no
no no no but but for real though like do
we have can we actually think of a
reason as to why this is like why do
people
buy so much toilet i don't know i
genuinely don't know i've been thinking
about it for however long this has been
going on maybe it has something to do
with people use toilet paper as tissues
now also
just because it's not the same thing i
guess no but no no no no no
that doesn't explain why people have
like three or four things of toilet
paper
chilling what is that thing you see that
what i don't know i'm just hoping it's
not i think
no i think it's a wasp oh okay great i'm
gonna say that's what happened
don't get stung but i'm pretty sure
that's a wasp all right
so for those that are that are chilling
right now we got a wasp flying around
maybe maybe this will make to the clip
we'll put it up on youtube i don't see
the wasp but i'm pretty sure that's a
wasp i'm gonna see it is
well that draws more wasps so
they sense death we had a nice breeze
it's been really really nice
so in other words we're more concerned
about the wasp in the coronavirus
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show every monday through
friday at 8 pm sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8pm monday through friday
or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts
every day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this youtube channel so don't forget to
subscribe
and stick around for more segments and
more shows monday through friday at 8pm
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you